well just when english cricket was
basking in the glory of the heroics at
trent bridge yesterday a reminder that
the racism scandal that started here at
headingley uh is still playing out in
the game and as you say the england
wales cricket board confirming that the
club itself and a number of individuals
will be charged in relation to
disciplinary
allegations arising from that racism
scandal this is what the ecb say in
their statement and it is quite
technical but it does explain
what the charges are about they say the
charges arise from alleged breaches of
ecb directive 3.3 conduct which is
improper or which may be prejudicial to
the interests of crickets or which may
bring the ecb the game of cricket or any
cricketer into disrepute and the ecb
anti-discrimination code the ecb's
investigation has been thorough and
complex with the allegations covering a
significant period of time and a number
of witnesses and other individuals
coming forward to share their own
experiences and allegations so we know
that the cricket disciplinary commission
will now investigate those cases in the
awesome there'll be a series of hearings
where those individuals and the club
will have the opportunity to put their
case forward and we will see exactly
what happens as a result of that and
this is a club of course that has been
through extraordinary turmoil they were
at the point of economic crisis when
this was at its height last autumn and
they've brought about significant change
with new leadership with lord patel and
darren gough coming into the club 17
members of staff were sacked as a result
of it and incidentally a few of them won
the cases of unfair dismissal just last
week but i think the the big landmark
for this club is that they have
international cricket back this week uh
next week rather against new zealand
test match cricket back at headingley
and that is an indicator that progress
has been made but nonetheless that match
will be played out in a situation where
the club is facing charges around its
handling of racism and i have just got a
indication from azeem rafiq himself the
original whistleblower in this who of
course you'll remember laid bare his
experiences during his playing career
that
really
shocked so many people when he spoke in
westminster azeem rafiq in the last few
moments has just put out this he said i
welcome today's announcement by the ecb
and hope we can move to the hearing
quickly this has been another grueling
but unfortunately necessary process it's
been a long two years azimuthique says
since i went public about my experiences
but i hope this all means that no young
player ever goes through such pain and
alienation again
so a significant moment in the game of
cricket with the ecb charging yorkshire
county group club and a number of
unnamed individuals around
their uh alleged behavior and handling
quite crucially of racism within qriket
yeah that's where we find ourselves
today tom but should we have a little
reminder of how this all began you
described as in rafiq there as a
whistleblower take us back to the start
of this how it all came to light
well the
allegations from azeem rafiq came
towards the end of his career and
charted back throughout from the age of
15
things that he experienced playing club
cricket and then county cricket
here at headingley during two spells in
his career and he laid bare a culture
that really
shocked many people inside and outside
of cricket as to how normal that had
become and it laid the groundwork for
many other people thousands of
complaints were made to the uh body set
up or in charge of looking at claims of
allegations of racism and discrimination
within the game and really what azeem
rafiq did was
a very brave move because of course that
came with a lot of attention it also
brought to light things that he had said
in his past uh that were anti-semitic
that he has had to confront in the
months that have
have come since uh he will first went
public with the allegations of racism
but it has fundamentally changed the way
cricket
thinks and has to think about its
approach and i think that is most
acutely felt here in yorkshire not just
because elite cricket needs to have its
house in order and so this some of this
stuff was just quite archaic in what was
uh described
but also the effect that it has on young
boys and girls who want to just get
involved in playing cricket at whatever
level in their community whether it's in
yorkshire or elsewhere and that has been
the fundamental reason as to why azeem
rafiq wants to challenge this and also
why the cricketing authorities are
trying to deal with it so robustly